the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi our lecture today is entitled inverse
functions and it's almost what you could
call a natural follow-up to our lecture
of last time when we talked briefly
about one-to-one and onto functions
inverse functions have a tremendous
application as we progress through
calculus but I've even more exciting
impact is the fact that inverse
functions are valuable in their own
right they are a precalculus topic in
fact they appear as early in the
curriculum as approximately the first
grade C roughly speaking inverse
functions in plain English mean that all
we've done is made a switch in emphasis
let's take a look at that let's go back
roughly to our first grade curriculum
when one learns that two plus three
equals five or that five minus three
equals two both of these statements say
the same thing but with a change in
emphasis
it's as if two is being emphasized here
while five is being emphasized here this
is rather interesting you see for
example in the new mathematics one talks
about subtraction being the inverse of
addition and this is the same inverse
that we want to talk about today as it
applies to mathematics in general what
do we mean that subtraction is the
inverse of addition it may sound fancy
but all it means is that if you know how
to add if you define subtraction
properly you automatically know how to
subtract and this of course is what's
prevalent in the old change-making
technique of going into a store making a
purchase paying for the purchase and
when you receive your change
the clerk rarely if ever perform
subtraction you may recall that what he
does is he adds on to the amount of the
purchase the amount necessary to make up
the denomination of the bill with which
you pay them in other words what we're
saying here is for example that one may
think of five minus three as being what
that number which must be added onto
three to give five you see in this sense
subtraction is the inverse
of addition once we know how to add we
automatically know how to subtract now
you see this idea goes with us we learn
that multiplication and division are
inverses of one another and as we go on
through higher mathematics even on the
precalculus level we find additional
examples of this for example when one
knows how to use exponents one
automatically knows how to study
logarithms namely if y equals the log of
X to the base B this is a synonym for
saying that B to the y equals x and what
is the basic difference between these
two statements they are paraphrases of
one another in one case it seems that
the number Y is being emphasized and in
the other case it's the number X that's
being emphasized and as in the case of
most examples of paraphrasing which of
the two forms we use depends on what
problem it is that we're trying to solve
in other words if we know one of these
two then we automatically can study the
other in terms of the one with which we
feel more familiar this of course
continues when one gets to trigonometry
and studies the so-called inverse
trigonometric functions if y equals the
inverse sine of X that's the same thing
as saying that X equal sine Y again what
is the basic difference in one case it
seems that Y is being emphasized in the
other case it's X that's being
emphasized in terms of the usual
calculus jargon of independent variable
versus dependent variable it appears
that what in one case X is the
independent variable Y the dependent
variable in the other case Y is the
independent variable X the dependent
variable to generalize this result what
we're saying is simply this if y equals
f of X you see where Y is being
emphasized the dependent variable if we
wish to switch the emphasis then we
write x equals F inverse of Y this is
read F inverse of Y and it's the
function which in a sense inverts the
roles of x and y let's see what this
means more explicitly in terms of a
particular
example let's suppose that we're given
the equation y equals 2x minus 7 or to
represent this somewhat more abstractly
y equals f of X where f of X is 2x minus
7 now you see without mentioning the
word inverse function it turns out that
early in our high school career we were
finding inverse functions as soon as for
example someone were to give us this
problem and say solve for X in terms of
Y solve for X in terms of Y you see if
we solve for X in terms of Y we now have
what X is being emphasized these two
statements tell us the same thing but
now we write what x equals F inverse of
Y and F inverse of Y is just y plus 7
over 2 see notice again the connection
between F inverse and F how one undoes
the other in terms of our function
machine idea what we're saying is we may
visualize the F machine whereby the
input is X and the output will be twice
X minus 7 in other words the output will
always be twice the input minus 7 now
the question that comes up is suppose we
reverse the rules of the output and the
input in other words suppose now we let
the input be Y what will the output be
if we reverse the terminal so to speak
what we have shown is that now the F
inverse machine would be what the input
is y the output is y plus 7 over 2 and
by the way a question that we shall come
back to very shortly that plays a rather
important role here and which I'll
emphasize from another point of view is
that if you get into the idea of always
wanting to call the input X and the
output Y which is how we get geared to
do things in terms of calculus you know
X is always the horizontal axis Y the
vertical axis and we always agree to
plot the independent variable along the
x axis in other words the input along
the x axis the output along the y axis
then the question is could we have
called this X
and call this X plus 7 over 2 and we'll
go into this in more detail in a little
while but obviously what we call the
name of the input should not affect how
the Machine behaves by the way as a
little aside I thought it might be
interesting to show why we use such
notation as F inverse F to the minus 1
it's rather interesting here let's
suppose we let a number go into the F
machine we call that number C notice
that any number that goes into the F
machine has as its output twice that
number minus 7
suppose we now let that number be the
input of the f inverse machine what does
the F inverse machine do it adds 7 on to
see it adds 7 on to any input and then
divides that result by 2 in other words
if we now run to C minus 7 through the F
inverse machine we have to C minus 7
plus 7 equals 2 over 2 equals C in other
words notice how the F inverse machine
undoes the F machine if we wanted to use
the language of last time in terms of
composition of functions what we do is
what what we're saying is that if you
can combine F followed by F inverse F
inverse followed following F that that
gives you all what we can call the
identity function the identity function
namely if the input is C the output will
again be C in other words F inverse of F
of C is just C back again in a similar
way notice that we can reverse these
roles we saw last time that composition
of functions depends on which order you
combine the functions but notice that if
you run D through the F inverse machine
the output will be D plus 7 over 2 if
this becomes the input of the F machine
remember what the f machine does it
doubles the
input and subtract seven in other words
again F of F inverse of D gives me D
back again in other words in terms of
composition of functions f followed by F
inverse or F inverse followed by F is
what we call the identity function that
one is truly the inverse of the other
from that particular point of view
however let's correlate what we're
talking about now with the circle
diagrams that we used in our last
lecture you see first of all let's
recall that unless our function is both
one-to-one and onto we do not have an
inverse function namely for example if
our function had not been on two then
when we see his the idea again let me
make sure this is clear to get an
inverse function essentially all we do
is this if F is a function from A to B
the inverse function is defined by
reversing the input and the output which
means in terms of this diagram we
reverse the sense of our arrows we
reverse which end the arrowhead goes on
and what we're saying is if we had a
function from A to B which was not on to
then you see when we reverse the
arrowheads f is not defined on all of B
in other words the domain of F the
domain of the inverse function would not
exist because it would not be defined on
all of B secondly if two different
elements of a went into the same element
of B when we reverse the arrowheads the
resulting function would not be single
valued and hence in terms of modern
mathematics it would not be a
well-defined function okay so in other
words for the inverse to exist it must
be that the original function is both
one-to-one and on through and as an
example of that this is what this
diagram here represents and to make sure
that we can read this alright I have
singled out a typical element of capital
A a typical element of capital B
remember what our notation is the
notation is that f of
a equals B that the image of a under F
is B and to use that in terms of the
inverse language if I call G the
function that I get when I reverse the
arrowheads G of B equals a and G is what
I'm calling f inverse by way of further
review the domain of F is equal to the
image of f inverse and that's a the
image of F is the same as the domain of
F inverse and that's B and now what the
question is is this notice that as long
as you want to use the same diagram all
we have to do to express F inverse in
terms of F is sort of to reverse the
arrowheads the question that comes up is
suppose you insist that the domain be
listed first in other words when we're
going to talk about G or F inverse in
this case that's a function from B to a
so why don't we list B first and you see
again we can do this here are the
elements of B here are the elements of a
and all we have to do is see what
happens over here for example if we come
back to here notice that the first
element listed in B comes from the third
element listed in a so when I make up
the inverse function I just capitalize
on this by writing the same thing the
only problem is and this is going to
become a crucial one is the fact that if
somehow or other you couldn't see these
labels if you couldn't see these labels
and all you knew was that the first set
was called a domain and the second set
was called the image if you now looked
at these two functions
you see they wouldn't look anything at
all alike in other words F and F inverse
while not independent of one another do
look quite different for example notice
that F inverse causes the first two
elements in here to sort of criss cross
as they have images and the second two
elements of here criss cross notice
though in terms of F it's the second and
third that crisscross and the first and
fourth that don't intersect at all this
way in other words if you look at this
curve or this
and compare it with this diagram notice
that there is a difference in what seems
to be going on well again this is quite
abstract let's try to relate this as
much as possible to the language of
calculus and our coordinate geometry
graphing techniques to begin with let's
suppose that we have a function f whose
domain is the closed interval from A to
B and whose range is the closed interval
from C to D and the question that we'd
like to raise is under what conditions
will F possess an inverse function what
does on 2 mean what does one-to-one mean
and things of this type well the first
thing I'd like to point out is that if
the graph y equals f of X looks
something like this do you notice that
the domain is from A to B the image is
from C to D notice the fact that we have
a break in the curve over here tells us
that our function is not on - namely
given this number P which is in our
image between C and D there is no
element of the domain that maps into P
so in other words if there is a break in
the curve the function is not on - and
hence it will not have an inverse okay
now suppose there is no break in the
curve let's suppose now that the curve
doubles back C it comes up and doubles
back now what my claim is is that the
function will not be one-to-one well how
can we see that pick any part where the
curve doubles back pick a point like
this in that range call that point Q
notice that Q is in the proper range of
F now C y equals f of X now the question
is given the Y value of Q are there any
x-values that map into Q under Y and the
answer is yes there are in fact there
are more than one name we notice that
both f of X 1 and f of X 2 equal Q in
other words in this case f of X 1 equals
f of X 2 even though X 1 is unequal 2 X
2 that means that this function
is not one-to-one and because it's not
one-to-one it doesn't have a
well-defined inverse function well
putting these two cases together what it
means for the function to be on - what
it means for the function to be
one-to-one it turns out that if a curve
is unbroken then the only way our
function can be one can have an inverse
function is that the curve must either
always be rising or always be falling
and it can't have a break in it and by
the way as an aside let me point out
here the difference between a continuous
variable meaning one that's defined on a
whole interval and a discrete variable
meaning where you get isolated pieces of
data notice for example if you plot y
versus X the way we do in a lab
experiment where for a particular value
of x you measure a value of y notice
that the data the data can double back
without the function being multivalued
in other words notice for example that
even though the curve doubles back here
I can call the curve the data doubles
back notice for example that no two
different pieces of data have the same
y-coordinate in other words given this
point here as being Q there is only one
piece of data that has its y-coordinate
equal to Q however of course keep in
mind it is possible it is possible that
another piece of data will have the same
coordinate all I'm saying is that the
idea of whether the curve always has to
be rising or falling certainly depends
on whether you have a continuous curve
or not well again let's continue on with
what inverse functions are all about you
see this comes up with our whole idea of
why do we make fun or why do we minimize
single valued functions in calculus and
the answer is that single valued
function that I'm sorry why do we always
stick the single valued functions and do
away with multi valued functions and the
answer is if you have a smooth curve we
can always break down a multi valued
function into a union of single valued
functions for example if we
take the curve see here as being y
equals f of X which plots like this
notice if I take the points at which I
have vertical tangents okay and break
the curve up at those particular points
in this case I'll get what curves c1 c2
and c3 notice that C is the union of C 1
C 2 and C 3 but that each of the curves
C 1 C 2 and C 3 are either always rising
or always falling in a similar way in a
similar way when we have a function
which doubles back and by the way notice
what the connection is between
multivalued and not 1 to 1 you see
notice that in terms of a function
versus its inverse function idea that if
a function is multi valued the interest
the inverse function cannot be 1 to 1 in
other words the idea being that when you
interchange the domain and the range you
see sort of the curve flips over idea
all I want you to see here is that what
if you're given a function which is not
single valued if we take the points that
which horizontal tangents occur and
break down the curve like this we can
break the curve down into a union of
one-to-one functions the hardship being
of course that when you start with a
point like this analytically speaking
it's rather difficult unless you invent
some scheme to know which of the points
here you want to single out in terms of
our previous experience it's sort of
like saying to a person I am thinking of
the angle whose sine is 1/2 there are
you see infinitely many functions whose
sine is equal to 1/2 of course if we say
to the person I am thinking of the angle
whose sine is 1/2 and the angle is
between minus 90 degrees and plus 90
degrees then the only possible answer is
the angle must be 30 degrees but notice
that when you have a function which is
not single valued the inverse will be a
multi valued function and we'll talk
more
about that in a little while again I
just want to keep the shotgun approach
going on just what an inverse function
is in relationship to the function
itself again let's look at this more
abstractly here I have drawn a curve
which is continuous and always rising so
I can talk about the inverse function if
the equation is y equals f of X the
inverse is written 1 x equals F inverse
Y and if this seems a little bit too
abstract for you think of a concrete
representation suppose the curve happens
to represent y equals 10 to the X then
another way of saying the same thing
would be x equals log Y the convention
of course here being that you don't
usually write base 10 but we won't worry
about that you see this is what two
different ways of expressing the same
curve you see whether I write y equals f
of X or x equals F inverse Y I have the
same curve this way in terms of our
arrows you see what I'm saying is if I
start with X 1 by going this way my
function determines the output Y 1
inversely if I start with y 1 and
reverse the arrows I wind up with X 1
again the basic difference being as to
which of the two variables is being
emphasized what the real problem is is
that most people say look at I'm not
used to studying curves this way I'm not
used to looking at the input being along
the vertical axis and the output along
the horizontal axis according to the way
I've been trained when we're studying
the inverse function in other words when
y is the input aren't we used to having
Y over here and then plotting the output
along this axis in other words the
question is given this graph how do you
arrive at this one you see somehow or
other let's observe that if all you did
was switch your orientation and say let
me look let me switch this by 90 degrees
notice that we would be in a little bit
of trouble in other words if we start
with this kind of a setup and we say
let's rotate
through a positive 90 degrees notice now
what we would wind up with is what our
x-axis would be the way we want it
but the y-axis would now have the
opposite sense of what we usually want
our input axis to look like so after we
rotate rotate through 90 degrees it
would seem that the next step is to do
what flip with respect to the x axis
that means fold this thing over in other
words a 90 degree rotation followed by a
folding over gives me the orientation if
I insist that the input has to be along
the positive or it has to be along the
horizontal axis and the output along the
vertical axis what I want you to also
notice though is that if we don't insist
on this there is no reason why we have
to use two separate diagrams again
notice these are two different ways of
giving the same equal to different
equations for giving the same curve it's
only when we want to switch the role and
make sure that the input is along the
horizontal axis that we have to go
through this kind of a process let's
look at this a little bit more
concretely what I call a semi-concrete
illustration what I'm saying now is
let's suppose this is the curve I've
drawn in here y equals f of X another
way of saying that is x equals F inverse
of Y and the question is suppose I now
want to plot the same curve same
equation but now with the y-axis as my
horizontal axis you see again in terms
of geometry how I shift my axes will not
change this equation but what the
picture of this equation looks like will
certainly depend on how I orient my axis
so the idea is what I simply fold this
rotate this thing through 90 degrees and
if I do that the resulting picture looks
like this and once the picture looks
like this the next step is what flip
this with respect to the x axis
okay and now my picture looks like this
in other words X equals F inverse of Y
here and X equals F inverse of Y here
are the same equation the reason that
the picture looks different is because I
didn't allow myself to use this as the
axis of inputs here in other words again
as soon as I wanted to make this axis
orient so it would be the horizontal
axis this is what I had to go through
over here now you see the next
refinement is that the person says look
at I'm not used to calling this the y
axis what's in the name why don't we
always agree to call the horizontal axis
the x axis and the vertical axis the y
axis and if I agree to do that notice
what happens just by changing the names
of the variables all that happens is is
that now this becomes y equals f inverse
of X this is an important thing to
notice them in other words if you insist
that the horizontal axis in both cases
will be called the x axis and the
vertical axis the y axis then this would
be the curve y equals f of X and this
would be the curve y equals F inverse of
X but again the whole thing comes about
only when you insist on how you want
your axis oriented let's go back to our
problem of y equals 2x minus seven and
see what this thing means in terms of a
graph as we saw previously if y equals
2x minus 7x is equal to y plus 7 over 2
and the idea is what let's see what this
thing really means if I plot the
straight line y equals 2x minus 7 this
is the line that I get notice that as
long as I'm going to use the same
orientation of axis here
it makes no difference whether I call
this line y equals 2x minus 7 or whether
I call it x equals y plus 7 over 2 they
are two different names for the same
line the problem occurs when I insist
that the independent variable always be
plotted along the x axis the horizontal
axis and the dependent
along the vertical axis again going
through what we did before I first take
this thing and I rotate it through a
positive 90 degrees that takes this
picture and transforms it into this one
I now take this and I flip it with
respect to the x-axis and that gives me
this picture here you see now what is
this line here it's x equals y plus 7
over 2 again this is the same equation
as this one the reason that the pictures
look differently is the fact that we
have changed the orientation of the axis
again if we now say okay let's rename
this the x axis let's rename this the y
axis then this becomes what y equals x
plus 7 over 2 it's in this sense that we
call this curve or this equation and
this equation here that these two
equations are inverses of one another
again in terms of what we said before if
you pick a particular value of x and
compute y this way then you apply this
recipe to that in other words if you now
take twice Y twice the output here and
subtract seven your original input
returns in other words this works
exactly the same as we did before but
again the whole basic difference is what
how you want to Ori orient your axes
that the curves look different because
your coordinate system is different of
course the interesting question now is
if we compare these two curves
since the C granted that the function
and it's inverse are different functions
they are somewhat related they're not
random how are these two graphs related
that might be the next natural question
to ask if we do that the idea is simply
this let's suppose we have y equals f of
X as one of our curves the curve happens
to be invertible meaning that f is
always rising and it's unbroken etc okay
the question is if we now try to plot y
equals F inverse of x in the same
diagram
see notice now what I'm saying in other
words I am NOT saying X equals F inverse
of Y here I'm saying suppose I have the
curve y equals f of X and also the curve
y equals F inverse of X how do these two
curves look with respect to an x and y
coordinate system so let me do that part
more slowly again let me come over to
here for a moment notice that y equals
2x minus 7 was my original curve and
what I dealt with before if I want to
keep the same orientation of axes the
inverse function we saw was y equals x
plus 7 over 2 the question that we're
asking quite in general not in this
specific case is how are these two
curves related and the solution goes
something like this
let's suppose that the point x1 y1
belongs to the curve C 1 by definition
of D 1 that says that y1 is f of x1 by
definition of inverse function see if y1
is f of x1
that means if you interchange the input
in the output that's another way of
saying what that x1 is f inverse of y1
in other words again if F Maps X 1 into
y 1 F inverse maps y1 into x1 by
definition now you see compare this with
the curve C to see this says what that
the input Y 1 maps into the output x1 in
other words notice that if you look at
the F in Juris situation here when the
input is y 1 the output is x1 that's
another way of saying that Y 1 comma x1
belongs to the curve C 2 in other words
if x1 y1 belongs to Y 1 equals F of x1
then y1 x1 belongs to y equals F inverse
of X now what is the relationship
between the point x1 comma y1 and the
point Y 1 comma x1 if we draw this
little diagram we observe that we
have a couple of congruent triangles
here this length equals this length this
angle equals this angle and this gives
me a hint
you see this makes triangle o P Q I saw
solis I draw the angle bisector of angle
o the angle bisector of an isosceles
triangle is the perpendicular bisector
of the base an angle bisector the vertex
angle is the perpendicular bisector of
the base well you see that makes this
angle equal to this angle that makes
this a 45-degree angle in other words
the line that I've drawn is indeed y
equals x and notice that p and q are
symmetrically located with respect to
the line y equals x in other words what
going back to our original problem here
the curve C 1 and C 2 are related by the
fact that they are mirror images of one
another with respect to the line y
equals x that's exactly what I've drawn
over here in other words going back to
the problem of how are the curves y
equal 2x minus 7 and y equal X plus 7
over 2 related the answer is they are
mirror images of one another with
respect to the line y equals x they are
symmetric with respect to that line now
you see let's talk about this forever
point of view also and show what the
tough thing is you see so far my whole
discussion seems to have hinged on the
fact that we have a function which is
invertible what if you have a function
which is none invertible going back to
something more familiar why do we talk
about what when y equals the square root
of x why do we have this convention that
we take the positive square root after
all doesn't the square root of x and
minus the square root of x have the
property that when you square them you
get the same result plus or minus
squared is always plus and the answer is
that if you square both sides here and
think of this as being the curve y
squared equals x what happens is you get
a multivalued function you see one value
of x year
- values of Y and the way we get around
that is we break this curve down into
two pieces C 1 and C 2 where C 1 is
always rising C 2 is always falling here
knows we broke this thing off at the
point of vertical tangency and we can
now think of this curve as being the
union of two curves one of which is y
equals the positive square root of x and
the other is y equals the negative
square root of x now the question is
what happens when you have a function
which is not single valued in other
words let's just invert this one let's
suppose we style with the curve y equals
x squared you see now for a given value
of y I'm in trouble because if y1 is
positive there are two different values
of x which yield this particular result
C in other words both of these have the
property that when you square them you
get y1 and all we're saying is that in a
problem such as this we can study this
curve as two separate pieces
call one of these curves K 1 that would
be the curve y equals x squared where X
is non-negative this will be the curve
of K 1 and call the other one K 2 where
K 2 will be what the same curve y equals
x squared but its domain is the negative
values of X in other words K 2 would be
this one over here and now the point is
if we deal with either of these two
pieces separately we can talk we can
talk about inverse functions now the
point is which of these two halves do we
use and this is where the word principal
values comes in and you see what I'd
like you to keep in mind is this a
little cliche I've written down here
it's called misinterpretation versus non
comprehension if you don't understand
what something means there's no danger
you're going to misinterpret it the
danger is when you think that you know
what something means and you have the
thing twisted around you see the idea is
this let's go back to our own friend y
equals sine X let's pick the value of y
equal to 1/2 say and now we say to the
person the same problem as we asked
before find the angle whose sine is 1/2
well the point is to find that angle if
I draw this particular line I can find
all sorts of candidates the point is
that what we try to do instead is to say
okay we'll now restrict the function
we'll break this down to be a union of
several curves in other words it will be
this curve Union this one Union this one
Union this one etc what do all of these
separate pieces have in common what they
have in common is that what they are on
to the range from minus 1 to 1 and on
that range
they are also one-to-one see that
one-to-one and onto every value of Y
between minus 1 and 1
is taken on along each of these pieces
and no value occurs more than once on
either of these pieces on any of these
pieces the point is it's not so crucial
whether you take this particular one or
whether you take this particular piece
that's something that's sort of
arbitrary what we must do to avoid
misinterpretation is unless otherwise
specified we say look at unless you're
here for me to the contrary let's always
agree that this is the little piece of
the curve that we're talking about or
this is the piece that we're talking
about but the idea being what unless you
make such a restriction we cannot talk
about inverse functions the idea being
that for an inverse function to exist we
must be able to back map we must be able
to go from the value in the image to the
value in the domain without any danger
of misinterpretation we can conclude our
example with returning to our y equals x
squared idea again you see the idea is
given the curve y equals x squared we
can think of it in terms of our pieces K
2 and K 1 as before the accented piece
being K 2 the non accented piece being K
1 and what we're saying is the inverse
of K 1 is this curve here which I'll
call K 1 inverse the inverse of K 2 is
this curve here which I'll call K 2
inverse
in other words the important thing is I
can find the inverse of either this
curve or this curve and in fact how do I
do that again with respect to the
45-degree line the line y equals x
notice that k1 and k1 inverse are
symmetric with respect to this 45 degree
line and similarly so our k2 and k2
inverse the thing I must be very careful
about and this is where problems occur
is I must not confuse for example what I
can't do is take for example K 2 and K 1
inverse see notice the built in idea
here these two curves together are not
symmetric with respect to the 45 degree
line you see what we're saying here is
is what that for this particular curve x
and y are both positive so obviously
anything that matches it must have x and
y both positive and that doesn't happen
over here so what we're saying is you
can't do these things completely at
random however what you can do is either
take K 1 and match that with K 1 inverse
K 2 and match that with K 2 inverse it's
not important which of the two ways you
do this as long as you understand that
there is a danger of getting mixed up
once the curve itself is not one-to-one
knows when we break the curve down into
one-to-one pieces we have to make sure
that we match these things up properly
now this is all we're going to say about
inverse functions for the time being the
rest will be taken care of in the
exercises in this unit however we will
return to this point very very strongly
later in our discussion of calculus the
important point to remember is that a
function and it's inverse function give
us two different ways of expressing the
same information and that we can use
whichever one happens to be to our
advantage well until next time goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate